as tekken shirts for a limited time
while supplies last yes these good ass
tekken shirts you see me rocking that
blue king shirt one of my favorite
characters my character mainstay also
comes
in black if you want to get yourselves
one use that qr code
go get one now limited edition
especially
if you want to get this lost shirt that
gold that yellow excuse me that yellow
and black
if you want to get yourselves one i saw
a rip rocking the yellow law and the
black law and now you're rocking the
yellow one too use that qr code if
you're going to get yourself someone as
good as tekken merch
and of course that cute ass tekken merch
still
there as well yoshimitsu leading the
charge we just saw one and personally
i'm a fan
of that uh that yoshimitsu on the white
but you can get yourselves either one of
the colors if you use that qr code
right there and thank you guys for
tuning in as we get
into this losers finals this will be
first to three if i'm not mistaken and
we have el negro
coming up against equinoxes joey fury in
the works cut out form it's cut out for
leroy 2.
leroy versus marduk that's going to be
our next match
all right here we go the last day on
earth stage
bro i can't believe this dude rip didn't
see the zombies in the background
you can like hear them sometimes too you
just got to get a proper sound system
you need some astros when you're playing
gotta use the astros bro
that's his problem man oh oh power crush
yeah i ain't got a parry but i got this
power though
nice first round of joey fury again joey
fury you know
he he's going to be a man on a mission
he's going to want to get back into the
grand finals
to fight off against break on the one
plus two domino
big damage and you're going to get the
wall like i said if there's a throw to
break that's the one to break because
not only will it knock you into the air
and put you into a world of hurt for the
juggle the wall carry your potential for
that it's also very very scary
and the sausage big damage he might be
done
down four four up full crouch down four
four to close out there you gotta be
careful taking right there but it's one
of those situations where you want to
either commit to the get up attack or
just do it anyway
with the whiff punish damage on the
table but man i don't know why that
angle came out of there
yeah that was very interesting oh blocks
the orbital
continues with the pressure here man
joey's looking at cruise control he is
not phased
by this pick at all i'm gonna tell you
look my man is not fazed by this damage
el negro is not because he's not
breaking any one of these throws the
full crouch down 4-4
and that is gonna get you the first win
in this first of three
versus joey fury man el negro is gonna
have to tighten this up man
joy fury has been in this situation way
too many times
like i said you know if there's a throw
to break it's that one he didn't break
three or four of them and that led to
his demise those rounds just went out
quick
and joey fury is in cruise control at
this point i have a feeling i mean
you know i don't think he needs to
change characters i think he can stick
to leroy still but he has to break that
throw he definitely has to break that
throw
no i mean look a lot of people look at
marduk and they're like man he doesn't
have a lot of tools but i'm gonna tell
you right now not every character in
tekken has
a combo that comes from a throat starter
marduk is one of those characters and
on top of that he has the okie he has
the damage and it has the wall carry
you have to break that throw if you want
to win against marta you have to
yeah it's crazy stuff crazy stuff either
way thank you guys for tuning in we are
in our losers finals right now
for the tekken 7 king of the hill finals
again
everybody that's been watching and
supporting throughout the entire series
for the last few months thank you guys
for being part of our community and
enjoying this tekken with us but also
thank you for just tuning in and
watching we just had that
uh that trailer reveal for lydia
and you know as an old-school tech event
i was super pleased to hear
uh and see a lot of the throwbacks for
that not only that excited for a new
character as always
i'm definitely look i'm gonna tell you
right now one of the things i love is
like character cameos especially when
it's inside the game character cameos
right so if you put in
a character in its stage that's even
more dope now
this dude lee moved to a bigger house
that's a different mansion he's got a
pool by his house now next to the beach
are you serious my man's balling like
that i mean he does
own violet industries so it does make
sense we're gonna go back to the match
don't listen to me
back to the match uh we have game number
two here cooney mitsu going up against
marduk i mean think about it though my
man's league he has to be bald and he
made combat
he's got an alter ego that's also rich
that's real money right there
i want my tasty steve alter ego to get
rich so i can live like that
all right here we go all right here we
go joey fury still
holding strong let's see how he does
here against kuni mitsu
well well i gotta say man
joey fury man also does music and a fan
of this stage man that's why i know he's
a man of like-minded nature
oh i mean if you ain't like-minded you
need to break that throw cause i
definitely will keep doing it
down four four four crouch down four
four to get that extra hit
and he's just kind of fishing right now
they're down for two
they're down four two full crouch down
four four four four two take the guess
and just does it again i
i like that and this is exactly what i
was talking about when we were looking
at cooney mitchell from the beginning
that guess is very important almost as
as important as that mata throw guess as
well
not getting the same amount of damage
but the guess the
the guessing game off of it is very
strong yeah it's very very important and
looking at the range there of that down
four two able to get it but not getting
the combo
which is just unfortunate but this time
eat this down back too
keeping him at the wall though i like it
and just crushed two two power crushers
right there
i like it he's using that as kind of
like a defensive option there that down
for two throwing it out there
trying to utilize the range and kind of
predict when joey fury's gonna be coming
in
this time breaking the graph this is
what you need to do yeah that would have
ended it right there too
and now got a round lead and got the
life lead after that hit breaking those
throws out
this is what we're talking about or
the bulldozer goes for the mid follow-up
after the dash
well that while rising one spins the
blue up four four
that's how you know my man joy fury is a
tekken professional
up four four we never see that move yeah
but we see it and when he does it he
lands it that's great stuff
um that there's that guessing game once
again tristan one and this is what i was
talking about forcing that extra guess
right there out of stance choke slam oh
let me do some different throws for you
okay pressure look at this bad position
for uh el negro to be and he's gonna
have to be very very careful
because you do not want to get plowed
into the wall there from marduk
oh wow i've never even seen that throw
before and that took off hella damage oh
my god oh my gosh
all right nice punish there yo my man
went for the jackhammer do it again
the air out of the sky dead able to
capitalize look at that just enough
damage
round four looking to tie things up here
joey fury
still battling though he is at a round
deficit but he can make the comeback at
any moment i mean marduk has so much
damage goes for the throw again man that
looks weird you see how limber my man
was
look look he is a mma fighter he's a
ballerina
man my man looks so majestic not wearing
that ugly ass outfit though all right
here we go
man my man went for the full body slam
you were right mark he's pulling out
all the different throws at this point
and now you see now you see el negro
getting a lot more active in the offense
drops a combo
there's the hop kick this should be the
round el negro could answer
back one match a piece hits the wall and
that's gonna be it
el negro answers back three rounds to
one in that second game
now we're talking hit him with the gang
signs it's for my mama bro
affiliation all the way look at that
down
rock for my mama that's what she did man
the upside down rock shout out to the
dame dash
for my mama that's what it's real it's
for it's for her mom
yeah she tells you she lets you know say
hey on my mom offender and then she
pulls out the night that's how you know
she's serious hey
i'm trying to win on my mama like oh she
means business
i mean how are you gonna doubt i mean
how are you gonna go against that for a
mother's love
that is always a good reason to fight in
the tournament right hey look man that's
how you know they mean if somebody say
oh my mama that's how you know they mean
it like look man i gotta go talk to this
guy
it's serious business on my mom i'm
gonna be like yo man go handle it man
i'm not gonna stop you but thank you
guys i'm not gonna stop you from this
good ass tekken that you guys are
watching
el negro answers back i'm gonna tell you
right now i was thinking
that el negro was not gonna make these
changes i was like this is gonna be
tough coming back from that especially
against joy fury jory fury
is definitely one of he's a hunter the
minute he knows he's like i could smell
the blood in the water the fury's coming
and he just goes crazy
but i feel like el negro getting a lot
more active in offense doing a lot more
pokes
that's what you like to see when it
comes from adjustments
um kuni mitsu can definitely throw you
in the mix when it comes to match-ups
so you have to be a lot more active you
have to make money respect your game
especially a player like joy fury
because if he knows you don't know how
to deal with the pressure
like not breaking that one plus two
throw he's gonna do it again
just to get the kill didn't work out
this time here comes game number three
well we're tied up it's gonna go looks
like the same characters so there's no
switch here from joey fury
i don't think he needs it but he did
make the right switch in the stage where
it could lead to so much damage however
kudimitsu does have a lot of tools that
can help benefit her
here in the forgotten realm she could go
quickly into the air grab
where it would go downstairs and really
eliminate a lot of walls and also
lead up to some great damage but either
way we'll see how it goes right into the
low starting it off
the power crush and and doing power
crushes like that in the neutral because
monarch has a
few slow moves right and if you see a
mark player get used to it
putting power crush in there is
definitely going to work out a little
bit not right there though that new move
we were talking about a little earlier
power crush once the game gets the wall
break and that should be the round
and just challenging joey fury in some
of these situations against the wall
is getting major payout fail negro oh
yeah it's definitely working out in such
a big way
wow the while standing three power slam
oh just a regular body slam
i love the adjustment cause he switched
to valley two sensor one for the grab as
well look at this he's just piling up
the damage at this point
oh he could have finished it
[Music]
round three fight
all right this time going in with the
low kick try to go for jackhammer once
again get off me lady
she got this suit clean i got to go to
work after this down 4-1 gets the launch
floor break we on the bottom floor
already the full house tour
i'm like a real estate agent bro we
trying to sell you this house
every room in the house he wants to show
you all features let me take you to the
walk-in closet now
give me a second how many closets you
have in here a lot
didn't break the oneplus two-throw gonna
eat the damage on the wall again oh
you're dead
have you seen the fireplace have you i'm
gonna put your body in it oh my god
joey fury and the lead right now let's
see what happens
but wait there's more right who's that
in the back
in the background is that cthulhu now
bro it's part of the house scenery
respectively
delayed hopkins oh my gosh that was a
sick punish but
you didn't get the follow-up there you
wanted the throw to switch positions oh
the stances
nope no break it's on the ground
the flames the fury using the blue stuff
the mount
guess for your life oh my god the dj
turntables
dj marduk you see i hit you with both
hands and then he stands up like he just
finished a killer set
at coachella with the with the fedora my
man hit you with the dj
uh uh i just had a sick senate coachella
guy see you next game and walks off man
with the fedora on that's how you know
that outfit is ugly because you got to
put a fedora on
with it that's that's how ugly it is bro
shout out to joey fury
for picking this ugly outfit and then
losing because of it let me see
for making something so ugly looks so
good right
but it's just like music it's just like
music man joy fury is uh
i feel like it's kind of like stacking
against him now the offensive side of
things is definitely paying off for el
negro
um and i feel like joey fury has always
been kind of like a
cautious player when it comes to these
kind of characters and you see him kind
of reaching out a little more when it
comes to the strategy and fighting but i
feel like this is el negro's playground
i feel like the faster el negro gets you
to play the better it goes for him
because
his scramble game is ridiculous and like
i said before
he's definitely been here before where
he's like you know what i might not be
you know showing up in every top three
top two
but i've definitely beaten some of these
people that you guys watch now
and i've been playing this game for a
long time joy fury in trouble
joy fury is in trouble right now if he
wants to hope if he wants to hope to
make it back to grand finals
and to potentially fight glaciating he
needs to turn it around right now
all right here we go this is a big match
it could go either way it might be
all over after this one but oh my gosh
steve you see this
the switch the raven
of the master joey fury
gonna happen i like i like this because
you know
the way that el negro plays master raven
is definitely one of the ones where he
likes to take charge and
put them into the blender and you'll see
that where the way he uses movement uses
that shadow step or that that snake step
to really try to force the opponent into
a mix-up
big damage big damage uh
almost half life right there uses that
miss trap cancel oh
look at the position power crush
good punish with the 2-1 trying to go
for the jackhammer good break
another launcher that's going to be the
first round oh man this is not looking
good once again
the answer back the adjustment from el
negro first round telling you man
that's so raven game number four
getting their mind reading abilities
making use of the step here looking to
cover some ground but right now joey
fury
poking away looking to get more damage
in quicksand
man the stand usage coming from el negro
not gonna mean anything
just a big launcher trying to get back
to that wall marta get the tackle
get off of me wow i'm out i'm out of the
corner
yep nice goes for the mid option there
good patients here from both sides the
cancel
good box solid
the dion sanders i'm high stepping into
the end zone gets the wrong
prime time he could have i mean he could
have kicked the damn field goal with
that you know
that was a nice counter hit of 4-3
anyways tied up on rounds
joey fury again with the game advantage
oh
oh my gosh that that boot is big and
look at this
joy fury starting to get the lead in
this set 2-1 on the side of george fury
as is el negro has to make some big
changes
outside of the master rape
nice look at this valley toodle pressure
good break there on the one throw
nice punish there and that's gonna make
you think twice about doing that because
you know joey fury obviously locked and
loaded ready with that downpour four oh
that new move new stuff
not to be confused with blue stuff
that's new stuff wow the float down back
to
can get the wall for sure down back to
no goes for the ground throw el negro
already
nice good option there goes for the
tackle continues with the pressure block
while standing three to get the launch
the wall is there what's the adjustment
um the bulldozer this isn't looking good
oh guess for your life is it the dj
no it's the two and that's gonna be it
joy fury
makes it back to grand finals gonna have
the run back against
my boy ben chang el negro going out of
the tournament
third place what an amazing showing in
all honesty once again one of those
players i've known for a long time
still making a splash here at the king
of the hill finals
but we have that winner's final run back
it will be ben chang
going up against joy fury first to three
again
but if joe fury wants a chance at bin
chang
uh or all right glaciating he's going to
have to beat ben chain
yeah two sets though two sets coming
from the losers bracket so it's gonna be
a race to three three out of five here
initially in our grand finals and if
he's able to win that first set
he wins one more whoever wins the second
one is gonna end up being the the
champion and go have the right to
challenge the current king of the hill
well it's definitely been a good time
i've seen you guys really active
on the twitters but just in case you're
unfamiliar if you want to follow any
of the tech in action first you need to
follow b
esports on youtube that's going to give
you all the replays you want to see that
sick new trailer
follow us at b esports as well as on
twitter for all the tournament
announcements you want more king of the
hill action tell us about it at b
esports and of course twitch.tv slash
tekken is the channel that you're
watching it on
and tekken at twitter as well as
facebook if you want to give us a follow
keep your ear to the streets as well to
stay up to date on all the tech and news
there is our socials give us a holler
let us know how you like it
and uh yeah of course man just a lot of
love to you guys tuning in
well with that being said we are going
to take quin
qui one quick break make sure you go